bonjour à tous un nouveau trailer de the
eternal est sortie et cette fois ci nous
ne sommes pas face à un simple prêt lors
on va dire qui instaurait l'ambiance du
film comme l'était le premier mais là
vraiment un véritable trailer qui
apporte du contenu de l'histoire et et
plusieurs éléments que j'aimerais
analyser avec vous et franchement il y à
pas mal de choses à dire tout d'abord il
y à une information très intéressante
que j'aimerais traités dès le début
c'est pourquoi les éternels n'ont pas
agi face à tan hausse comme expliqué par
à jacques qui est un petit peu la sage
du groupe capable de communiquer avec
les célestes et bien les éternels
agissent seulement que lorsqu'il y a des
déviants dans l'histoire bon c'est un
petit peu une pirouette pour expliquer
pourquoi les éternels était absent
depuis tout ce temps mais surtout cela
confirme une information très importante
c'est que thanos du coup n'est pas un
déviant comme il l'était dans les comics
et que beaucoup suspecté d'être pour le
mc pour rappel thanos est un fils
d'éternel mais posséder en lui et le
gène d'evian ce qui explique un petit
peu sa supériorité en termes de pouvoir
d'intelligence ou encore son physique
hors norme bref donc d'accord les
éternels n'agissent que lorsqu'il y à
des déviances pour ceux qui ne se
souviennent pas ou qui ne le savent pas
les déviants et les éternels sont
d'éternels rivaux oui je les fais exprès
en gros les célestes ont créé les deux
races sauf que là où les éternels sont
des bg en puissance des protecteurs des
héros parfait quoi et bien les déviants
eux possède un physique aléatoire est
très hétérogène ils sont hostiles et
sont les ennemis des éternels qui
protège l'humanité face à ces derniers
bien du coup par rapport au trailer
c'est très intéressant qu'à jacques nous
affirme que les éternels n'agissent que
lorsque leurs ennemis les déviants sont
présents puisque cela nous confirme
implicitement que les déviants ne sont
pas parus depuis très longtemps dans le
sens où dans toute l'histoire du mc eut
connu à l'écran nous n'avons jamais fait
face à une menace déviant sur terre et
donc que les éternels n'ont pas eu à
intervenir éternelle qui d'ailleurs sont
tous dispersés depuis des siècles chacun
fait sa vie de son côté cela appuie
encore l'idée qu'ils n'ont pas eu à
intervenir depuis un très long moment
alors c'est là que les grandes questions
arrivent pourquoi maintenant qu'est-ce
qui va se réveiller eh bien je pense
personnellement que le film des éternels
restera quand même assez fidèle à
l'histoire des comics à jacques nous dit
que le snap effectué par l'humanité pour
ramener tout le monde à générer une
puissante énergie qui va provoquer ce
qu'elle appelle l'émergence et c'est un
mot qui n'est pas choisi par hasard
quelque chose qui émergent c'est quelque
chose qui se relève qui sort de l'eau
par exemple des profondeurs des abysses
et du coup bah pour moi le lien avec les
comics est tout trouvé effectivement
dans l'histoire des éternels chargés de
protéger la terre face aux déviants
leurs créateurs les célestes leur rente
par moments une petite visite à lors des
visites espacées par plusieurs milliers
d'années bien évidemment ces visites
servent pour les célestes à voir si la
terre se porte bien il juge son état en
quelque sorte et dans l'histoire il y à
une visite au particulière où les
célestes ont décidé d'anéantir les
déviants car ces derniers s'étaient
reproduits en trop grand nombre ils
étaient des millions au point même où
ces derniers renier carrément sur la
terre les éternels n'ont pas eu d'autre
choix que de faire appel au céleste pour
intervenir face à un monde de chaos avec
des déviants agressif envers les
célestes ces derniers on taira dick et
la plupart des déviants et ont noyé leur
capital ainsi que l'atlantide au passage
c'est là que c'est intéressant car c'est
la même symbolique koenders elle sait
que les humains sont à la surface et les
monstres sont dans les sous sols dans
les souterrains car effectivement oui
les déviants qui ont survécu se sont
cachés dans les profondeurs dans les
sous-sols de la terre et
et comme des bannis des ermites en
quelque sorte mais l'histoire ne
s'arrête pas là bien évidemment mais bon
c'est déjà pas mal pour un premier film
ce serait du coup que l'émergence
traduirait le retour des déviants des
profondeurs de la terre des tréfonds et
caetera et qu'ils reviennent à la
surface du coup pour mettre le bazar
quoi des images du trailer correspondent
d'ailleurs à cette idée par exemple nous
voyons et carris affronter un déviant
qui sort de l'eau la symbolique est très
importante ici ou encore je pense que
nous faisons face à une manipulation du
trailer lorsque nous voyons quelque
chose tomber sur la terre car la scène
qui suit nous montre la terre se
déformer lots s'agiter comme pour nous
montrer l'impact de la chute sauf que il
se pourrait que cette déformation de la
flore soit due à l'émergence plutôt des
déviants et pourquoi pas leur cité si
l'on décidé de l'implémenter dans le mc
concernant la chose qui tombe sur la
terre je pense personnellement à la
visite des célestes effectivement
pourquoi nous donner l'information que
les éternels ont sept jours pour tout
géré et comment amener et justifier la
présence des célestes sur la terre est
bien par le biais de leur visite tout
simplement pour voir si tout est en
ordre d'après ce qu'on pensait depuis le
début et les visuels du trailer ce
serait arish m le céleste juge qui
viendraient déterminer si la terre
mérite de continuer perdurer ou non
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas anodin que ce
soit à jacques qu'ils nous fassent part
de l'information 17 jours car c'est
cette dernière qui communique avec les
célestes dans le groupe d éternel donc
tout l'enjeu sera là pour moi
contrecarrer les déviants pour la visite
des célestes est d'ailleurs un petit mot
comme ça par rapport au céleste mais
j'étais très curieux de voir comment ils
seraient amenées pour le mc une comment
ils seraient montrés et au vu de leur
taille gigantesque respecter ça promet
un jour un énorme galactus imposant
c'est vraiment trippant bref concernant
cette prochaine visite des célestes en
rapport avec les déviants il semblerait
dans le trailer que nous ayons la
présence de croo un véritable seigneur
de la guerre et déviant légendaire qui a
traversé les âges et dirigé bon nombre
de ses collègues d'evian nous avions
d'ailleurs parler de lui dans la
première vidéo alors pourquoi je pense
qu'il s'agit de croo et bien
premièrement car il est la figure
emblématique et la plus connue du peuple
d'evian il est très lié également au
groupe des éternels dans son histoire et
surtout par le biais du trailer via ce
qui nous est montré il est en compagnie
de tena les deux personnages sont
ensemble ce n'est pas un autre éternel
c'est bel et bien tena qui est montré
avec cros et cros semblent montrer un
geste d'affection pour cette dernière et
bah justement dans les comics tena et
cros ont une grande histoire d'amour
dont je vous avais déjà parlé évidemment
le trailer est prêt si rien n'est dû au
hasard
et cette romance entre cros et ena ou
même encore celle de sorcy et dane vont
permettre de nous démontrer et
d'illustrer les rapports que ce soit
entre éternelle et déviants ou éternelle
et humain par exemple étant donné que
nous sommes dans le mc eu il y aura
forcément une réécriture un remaniement
de l'histoire des comics est-ce que les
déviances sont tous si mauvais est-ce
que crowe sera différent au vu de sa
relation avec tena est ce que tous les
éternels sont si bons que ça ce sont des
thématiques que j'espère voir dans le
film druide pourrait retourner sa veste
par exemple comme il l'a déjà fait dans
son histoire bref je veux voir tout ces
complexités sans oublier également le
syndrome frankenstein 1 comme j'aime le
dire souvent c'est que évidemment les
éternels ne vont pas rester indéfiniment
liée seulement aux déviants ils vont
forcément intervenir un jour dans le mc
lui pour d'autres cas de figure et c'est
ce qui veut dire que nous allons
forcément à un moment donné faire face à
l'émancipation des éternels face à leurs
créateurs les célestes d'où le syndrome
frankenstein la logique voudrait qu'à
riches m soit au final une menace pour
la terre que ce dernier portent un
jugement négatif est que les éternels se
retourne donc contre lui pour protéger
les humains après tout ils ont éduqué et
aider l'humanité et comme ils le disent
si bien ce qu'on aime on le protège
enfin voilà écoutez c'était une petite
vidéo sur ce second trailer et ce
trailer final des éternels et j'espère
que cela vous aura plu concernant le
personnage de black knight joué par kit
harington on en a pas beaucoup parlé
aujourd'hui mais je pense toujours qu'il
servira de point de repère en tant
qu'humain pour les spectateurs et
justement servir à montrer la relation
entre eux éternel et humain mais les
stars du film évidemment ce sont bel et
bien les éternels donc son tour viendra
forcément un jour ou l'autre bref on se
retrouve pour de nouvelles vidéos très
vite la prochaine sort dans la semaine
je pense qu'il va être temps de reparler
de spider man 3 en attendant n'oubliez
pas de vous abonner à la chaîne a laissé
un petit pouce bleu et un petit
commentaire concernant le trailer ce que
vous en avez pensé est ce que vous
attendez du film pourquoi pas et puis
voilà que le lie à nouakchott avec vous
cet argot rock allez ciao tout
[Musique]